service und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video und damit auch zu einer
neuen bestzeit challenge heute kam auf
weniges kanal eine challenge haben wir
versucht den tresor zu gucken wer die
beste wer die schnellste runde hin
kriegen kann das vielleicht machen wir
es auch bei mir auf einem kanal eine
jump league und spielt nämlich jeder 2
jump n runs und dann wird gecheckt wer
die schnellere runde bekommen hat und
der gewinner ist verschont
der verlierer gegen dritte ganz
klassisch einfach vom anderen in fucking
badesee gestimmt oder vielleicht doch
erwartet das risiko dass jemand das
läuft oder stirbt dann den ganzen apfel
deren wünsche was löw über sein deswegen
unseren see soja und jetzt muss ich
versuchen
ich habe am anfang ist ein bisschen
holprigen start zu suchen hier die
bestzeit aufzustellen
ich habe zwei versuche uns da es danach
hat wie nie auf zwei versuche damit
geguckt wer der flotteste hier auf den
germany kann es ist wenn man es nicht
ins ziel schafft dann ist die runde
ungültig das heißt dass die nicht
gezählt wird
da aber passiert die beste runde treten
keine kisten egal wie ich das land bis
die macht der gewohnheit vor allen
dingen jump liga zwei minuten später
zwei videos und 20 kinder gespannt die
relation sein wird zweite amtszeit und
wieder aufgestellt fabrik viel schneller
oder langsamer sein sich sagte jobs
langsam derzeit weiter bis zu zehn
minuten also die monster die mit ihren
800 menschen blickt wirtschaft aber
glaubt dass noch weitere gelder
schneller ist weiters sind aber die
letzten halt einfach schwieriger sind
die skalierung ist ein anders die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür immer an einem
modul gangs ist sehr sehr geringe
eigengewicht wirtschaftlich passieren
wie kann das passieren natürlich bleibt
drei minuten letztlich sollte man
zwischen hier und da das ist schlecht
nicht du bist erst das disqualifiziert
sich schon mal den schweden keine chance
bisschen ärgerlich als abgepasst
so kann jetzt nicht gehen rabatt kaka
soll das paradies geschaffen damit die
jetzt hat er richtig bitter ist das für
module in den kopf schoss mit dem ich
zum ersten mal
ich habe es heute vormittag schon einmal
gehabt habe ich habe ich einfach so aus
man ohne gespielt aber ich hab das modul
auch zum erst mal gesehen nein hier so
nie gesehen dass ein anderes genau und
amtlich wie in trance auch ganz stark
davon ab welche module angekommen ist
deswegen kann weiter suche genau das ist
übrigens vier minuten 24
das alter variiert aber er hat
funktioniert so ist haben natürlich das
gleiche bekommen sondern aus meinen
fehlern lernen kann
dieses modul das bricht einem ganz
schönes genäht
hey leute das wird vielleicht keine
bestzeit hier gerade alte ich waren die
leute dran
hättest du dir das mal an bord denn
jetzt bitte ich noch irgendein fähigkeit
leute was ist los 11
da noch eine kiste erneute leute langsam
dass dieses echten großes modul muss man
halt mal sagen nein das gibt es nicht
mal wie lange soll das noch seien 650
also erst noch war das ist der absolute
witz hier ganz raus
ein fake kann man die erste runde ist
unnötig zittern
so würde das ohne war holprig gesagt
deswegen versuchen wir bei der zweite
unser glück weiß nicht so mitbekommen
wer aber bei der sache
das licht ist nicht glücklich losgezogen
mit dem modul was jetzt kommt
das alles ist natürlich etwas gibt das
nehme ich das nämlich jetzt auch nicht
schwer und dann hast du diesen planeten
also es ist eine buslinie sowie
drogenabhängige auf dem tisch alter
schwede
minute setzt voll mal beim ersten gut
fertig glaube ich jetzt mal nicht
losgelaufen alles minute die ich
halbwegs schon mal gesehen habe diese
halbwegs auf anhieb geschafft habt aber
wie gesagt das ist auf jeden fall eine
gehörige portion glück
die routine ohne witz ahs ist für 2020
als passt halt weg ich bin happy solange
ich nicht das geringste modul bekommen
das kann ich nämlich einfach mal gelinde
gesagt aber es ist generell nicht so
schnell keine langeweile auf
ja okay das gegenteil checkpoint hier
es geht voran leute drei minuten stand
polizeirevier das letzte chance
das ist schon okay es ist der ring stand
ist nicht dabei leute ich bin gerechnet
so weit schlimmer war flog durch die
ewigkeit zwischenruf drei tage später 24
25 minuten 6 gewissen da ist das ding
jetzt wo harry module an das alles
schwieriger ob der module
ich sag mal ich hab alles alles so um
die fünf minuten es eigentlich ein
verdammt guter zeitung sun peaks und man
muss sich vorstellen ein modul geben wo
ich ein bisschen hängen bleiben also
wenn du jetzt zweimal das bringe nicht
sein
wie kommst du bist einigen hf würde ich
mich jetzt persönlich nicht bei den
verbrauchern beschweren muss ich sagen
okay das songmaterial fläche sack und da
ist der checkpoint und 512 jetzt muss
ich ran
ein paar wochen später so leute wenn
jetzt besuchen
43 21 und jetzt schluss alles klar
weißt du was was jetzt eine controls
drin
das wiki dass der triqui aber kann sie
trotzdem mal probieren sich schnell um
das muss ich jetzt machen weil sonst die
zeit steckte mit ausarten ich glaube das
passt ja das was mir alles klar das land
so 10 15 sekunden vor der halbzeit
abziehen soll es am ende darauf hin dass
es für module ist das pils modul dieses
modul was einfach zehn jahre dort
das ist richtig bitter diese module dort
das hat echt lange ja und da die ferne
ist ausleihen gefahren das jahr hattest
du auch muss er genau ist auch dass
leichen die zeit sagt 55 sekunden 512
ist die zeit die es zu schlagen gilt so
letzten endes hängt eigentlich alles
davon ab welche hatten
ich glaube auch ja also ich glaube dass
es gibt ja wie sie mit dir natürlich
lange dauert oder einfach abhaken so zum
beispiel das mit den in das becken wird
so ein klassiker ist medien module in
europa dran gedacht also wenn das
bekommst dann ist halt echt richtung
schwarz ziemlich lang hat ein zweites
modul ist absolut ist es super easy dein
erstes haben das macht war das zweite
super easy bietet das richtig gesehen
habe leichtesten hat module weihnachten
wie heißt das hier ist nämlich eines der
leichtesten hat das stimmt tatsächlich
leuchtet es gibt wieder hinter das habe
ich noch nie gesehen habe ich noch nie
gesehen glaube ich krieg sie auf der
liste es wäre auch nicht schlecht oder
das ist das ist tricky das hättest du
das ist die man kenne sich das ist
negativ geht es habe ich bisher in
meinem ganzen leben auch einmal
geschafft
doch ich kenne das alles ist so schwer
hat das ist rechtlich mag vielleicht den
hier im moment los österreich drei
minuten sagte zeit ich muss ihr frostig
sein ich mache sie mal zu schnell wieder
springen
das ist also eine tiefe steinblock los
es wird diese eine ganz ganz tiefen
steinblock weekends wahrscheinlich kennt
ihr das absolute autonomie 0
euro also unter gewesen das kann es ja
nicht sagt 445 und schaffe ich schon
nicht mehr noch das wird 512 jetzt
bisschen eng würdig seien erfreulich
aber noch zwei module vor mir das wird
nichts mehr
also es gibt die runde ist alles klar
leute inzwischen 765 geläutet ersten
module sehen menschlich ausbauen
dass die stadt storkow läuft als gewiss
weil eine erste nicht gekündigt
beide der zweiten runde gut weggekommen
vom stadion button beide jetzt
analysieren erstmal das problem das wir
sehr sehr schwierige bis fast uns
persönlich unlösbare mitbekommen haben
ich hatte in den zweiten blick auf dann
23 kia-modelle machbar aber tricky aber
die chance es sollte sie ab juni bekommt
deshalb sehe aber es ist eher das ist
dieses modul war eigentlich echt ein
guter punkt so also wäre wenn er dann
noch ein zweites kapitel ist so dass ein
drittes was lösbar gewesen
jetzt habe ich eine bombe zeit hingelegt
kommst du auch sehr gut voran muss ich
sagen 112 und module 6 was da ansteht 06
ja alles klar
bomben zeit soweit kennt kennt auch
nicht aus ihrem extrem viele neureiche
horn sieht aber sehr machbar aus
eigentlich denkt auch deswegen habe ich
solchen beschaffen ok und dann das
kalkül ist unbelastet für deine hartmut
so wie es aussieht ein zeitfenster von
drei minuten ich werde wenn ich jetzt
richtig nein
weißt du online was ist dieses modul
rolleyes ist vorüber so drauf es wurde
und sich bei der blöcke von kompost das
ist new york die schwierigste topic dass
sie noch das ist halt findet ihr ja ok
aber eher stark das ist stark anlaufen
der software merkt 240 seiten der doppik
speech man entscheidet sich heute wer
baden geht es jetzt gesagt oh wie schön
ist der checkpoint
das ist alles schwierig das hatten wir
doch erst mal gegeneinander gelaufen
letztens macht krass jetzt ist richtig
dicken assistiert recht zwischen einen
trick des genauen stimmenzahlen
aufgerichtet das letzte mal gab schon
viel gesehen das ist dieser bücher tour
sieht aber hausbesitzer jetzt führen die
größte schwierigkeit genommen hier oder
das ist die frage hast jeweils wieder
das überdecken die zeit sagt drei
minuten 45 leute und wenig nähert sich
dem letzten modul das ist halt der größe
ab verkehrspunkten verbunden
das ist halt auch dusche von solarbuzz
ja was muss er doch der leiter
wegspringen das ist das schwierigste was
in templin restlichen gehen und erneut
waren gespielt da habe ich noch 412 sagt
muss versuchen jetzt hier schnell du
hast du denn da ist jetzt keine denke er
deckt das problem ist dass du dich nicht
schaffst du nicht ganz einfach doch ist
uns hier werden becken kommt erhält ist
es ganz vorne bieten
nein außerdem engagiert sich seit die
zeit
zwei module vor dir was wir ersetzen
gewesen setzte was bücher das ist ganz
so schwer das geht eigentlich und 514
sagte uhr leute das war jetzt schon fest
mit der grundlast immer gut geschlagen
am ende ist auch eine frage des glücks
das pech zu sagen mit angespannter klar
bereit dazu später so leute wenn ihr
macht jetzt sagen sie mal fertig hier
vorne liegen die schon lange gesichter
ich sehe das doch denn der muss jetzt
hier gleich in die donau sprengel nicht
wahr und die sache ist wie meine viele
teams ist es warm aber wir hatten eine
woche lang nur regen und gewittern ihn
uns heute so schön und fängt das wasser
doch ziemlich kalt meinst du überlebst
es halt die donau ist voll mit alten
gebäude gibt auch krokodile
ein mann geht es einem schicksal
entgegen worden links konnte
die tiefe testen haben wir relativ
schnell hinter welchen dass mich meine
badehose mit also sc motor an
ich weiß ich muss wissen wie es um
frische leute so machen wir das jetzt
wie schätzt den rand macht die augen zu
damit sich zu langweilig ist spricht
selbst rein sondern wir schenken soll
also sagt bescheid über die augen
zumachen
aber es geht weniger hat damit seine
bestrafung quasi eingelöst man munkelt
es gibt noch einen anderen hier für uns
beiden die auch eine bestrafung eines
muss man hier verabschieden uns mit
diesem wunderbaren blick von der donau